♪ (FUNKY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
MICHAEL CHOW: When I was young,
I wanted to become a painter.
I painted religiously.
But you learn very quickly...
China, in the west,
was nothing.
They say, "No, you can't
be a painter.
You can't do anything."
Except for restaurant
or laundry.
So he said, "I'm not going to
do a laundry,
I'm doing a restaurant."
SPEAKER: He had to invent
a whole new persona.
SPEAKER 2:
The name "Mr. Chow."
CHOW: I wanted to
create respect.
Respect for my country.
Because no one had called him
Mr. Chow.
Chinese in low of low.
So I want to show them
we are the chic of chic.
This is theater.
We're looking for transcendence
to a higher place.
The restaurant was crazy.
SPEAKER 3: All the Hollywood
is there.
It was a safe place for
a lot of people.
But Mr. Chow is a character,
created by him.
Of the man who doesn't want
people to know
who he really is.
Give me black and white
with a stick, please.
My father was completely
an artist.
Revolutionized the
Beijing Opera.
He said to me, "Wherever you go,
always remember,
you are Chinese."
Woo!
♪ (INSPIRING MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
The problem with racism,
it hurts.
You take away my glasses
and take away my Rolls-Royce,
I'm not good enough now.
SPEAKER 4: These paintings
speak about turmoil.
About tension.
But they're also
very joyous and free.
Woo!
SPEAKER 5: Art and creativity
is something
that is very important to him.
It's one of the things
that makes us human.
CHOW: The most important
thing about artists,
it's their job to be true
to their time.
True to their dream.
And above all,
true to themselves.